yeah I hate liberals okay welcome all
right so Michael Steele who will be the
next GOP candidate to drop out of the
race
oh good good question uh that's got to
be tough there's no incentive for anyone
to get out right now the way the jockey
there the way the primary is sake the
way the primary says his wife said to
him this morning that you're running for
president you gots to go though now the
way the primary set up between February
1st and March 15th everybody gets a
proportion of the vote so I hang in
there and I get a little piece I get a
little piece and I gather leverage at
the end wise you can live in a hotel and
write Neil's up until the day you
actually say you're out right just if
you've got a half a million bucks in the
bank
I must will run from nother two weeks in
right boggle exactly yes Sarah Palin
dined on a long time astra how can
non-muslims support efforts of moderates
great question they can speak the truth
yes you dared to do what you stood in
front of a hotel and you said boycott
this hotel
well that wasn't that hard really right
but you took a position I yeah but I'm
an issue with that because it's kind of
tokenism the people who need to go spot
your soup at the Beverly Hills Hotel
okay you know I mean if they think that
they have a problem that they think that
that's going to solve the problem they
don't think is going to solve the
problem it just shines light on the
right and I'll tell you what happened
for me then is because you dared to do
that and then your wife dare to take on
the issue of the Taliban yeah right
right
early then I decided that yes we've got
people who talk common sense and at last
a month
put a change.org petition my first one
ever
hashtag boycott Saudi because right and
people have the courage to sing make
make a liberal ideas socially
unacceptable
that's exactly so even if it comes off
as a lead ism or all of these other
names and smears that it's are thrown on
people take it take a hit right yeah I'm
not gonna kill you yeah cuz you have to
because did we protest when and also I
may say Q yeah
do some research right I think a lot of
Americans have no idea they know a
Muslim in America where it's great to be
a Muslim because you can be a cafeteria
Muslim or you can leave the religion
right that's not the experience of the
million-and-a-half
Muslims around the world for the most
part you can't just up and leave the
religion you can get killed for that you
can't just be gay get killed for that I
mean you bring so you bring a spotlight
on those poor atheist bloggers who are
being hacked to death yeah and where are
the Liberals standing up for that and
you had that great line that he said if
we were chopping heads in Vatican square
would we think there was something wrong
with that right they chop off the heads
at the homosexual yeah so I was against
the chopping of heads I just want to say
that he took the Pachanga a little
wobbly but I said no I think this is
and and what we're gonna do is I know
when you guys go home you're all going
to sign the petition
no all-male panels we almost covered
don't want to hang out with the boys
transitioning I don't want to be rude
for Paul Reiser what can you tell us
about your new project regarding Johnny
Carson hmm I'm not sure I might get a
spot on the show is open for what oh
you've got a Johnny Carson project I
don't know about this I I'm working on a
show that takes place in in when the
karlon The Tonight Show moved to LA it's
about a kid who gets a job in the
entry-level thing we have access to all
the shows which most people not seen so
we can intersperse footage of the show
in the thing that's gonna be very cool
to you is this on another platform
another platform it's just in a pill
form remember changes when you wake up
Johnny usually it's on another network
but now it has to be another media
delivery so you tell me that I couldn't
say watch NCI on another night couldn't
say CBS there's only two other networks
what if it was Congress right to ban
Guantanamo Bay detainees from relocating
to the US oh this is so stupid you know
I think one of the last things Obama
would like to do before he leaves office
checked off his list of stupid [ __ ] is
two fellows first thing on his list and
that might change now that what was
going on why because of fair enough
because of Paris I think so I mean how
many civil liberties and liberties will
be eroded because of this you know guy
what maybe we should profile you know
anything because they say none of the
surveillance all for all the gajillion
dollars we spent on surveillance and NSA
this and tracking that they say this
entire Paris thing there was nothing if
they had no that was almost a full
Montano mo they are not American citizen
so they come to this country they get
the right
to get all the protections and the right
that's why they're not recently
you have the judicial problem then you
also have the NIMBY problem where you
know the question becomes which state do
you send them to which federal system do
you put them in well not to mention if
they weren't bad if they weren't bad
when we put them in Guantanamo I can
rest assured they don't like as much
coming out of the wait wait a second but
we're not describing what the Republican
response to this is which is that these
guys are so dangerous that they cannot
be on American soil like their the ocean
Elevens gang like there's some sort of
criminal masterminds who even if they
were in a Supermax we'll find a way to
break out cuz I can tell you that I went
down to Guantanamo took the Miami air
jet that the Miami Heat uses when
they're not taking journalists down to
Guantanamo sat in the spectator gallery
Khalid Sheikh Mohammed the mastermind of
9/11 comes in he's got the full-on
Pakistani clothes that we've bought for
him at halal Co in in Fairfax County
Virginia because we're culturally
sensitive he's not wearing a prison
jumpsuit he's got his white hair dyed
red from berries that he got so he has
the pious Muslim look it's a signal and
so we're bending over backwards doing
this cultural gymnastics instead of just
prosecuting them right and that's what
we need to do we need to just even if
it's at this point whatever intelligence
you were going to get out of them after
15 years you should have gotten it right
well said we should worry the ones that
are innocent quote-unquote and then and
then prosecute the ones and not put all
these hoops through okay Thank You panel
you